this is just straight [ __ ] facts
99.9% of people that you judge or have
opinions on you have no idea what the
[ __ ] is actually happening in their
lives let's just start there the fact is
you probably only know what four or five
people actually have going on and even
then you don't know as much about your
sister in your parents as you think so
who the [ __ ] are you you got your
perspective it's offense I think people
say no too often because they fear
ramifications
I don't think micro losses are scary and
empowering people to make decisions is
how you scale and to me I've always
thought that somebody doing an 86
instead of my hundred is better than not
doing it at all plus how am I ever gonna
learn if somebody is capable without
giving them a chance like eventually you
have to let your kids swim eventually
you have to let them swing the bat and
so yeah I'm I'm I'm completely not
driven by fear and people are and the
reason people don't let people do things
as they fear it or they have I mean it's
ego a lot of people don't want there are
understudies or their direct reports or
the people they manage to be better at
something than them it's just insecurity
I'm massively secure in myself and then
I
that's exactly right Campbell is a good
insight and you're doing a good job with
this and asking me these questions like
I say yes I give trust at first you can
lose it people like clusters earned I'm
like cool that seems [ __ ] slow and
egotistical like who the [ __ ] am I to
have it earned you know like great like
[ __ ] that to me Trust is given and then
you lose it if you're a [ __ ]
uncapable incapable excuse me and and
have proven that you're not you're not
worthy of the challenge
the or the role I think one thing I've
noticed though that is a counteract to
my move is that a lot of times when you
accelerate that too soon
people become entitled they get they in
the micro get a little bit of a high in
their supply and they think they're big
[ __ ] and they start having egos
underneath you when you weren't like
watching my people that I empower with
like I trust you blindly then not trust
people blindly underneath them is uh is
heartbreaking happens often and is
something I'm thinking a lot about I
don't I see what people actually do
naturally themselves then try to
micromanage and I think a lot of people
never get a true read on somebody
because they've over manipulated their
tasks and the person is doing exactly
what that boss wants and to me to me
ultimate scale is allowing people to
roam free and expose themselves it's
kind of like that rope right I'll give
you a rope and you can go forever or you
can hang yourself with that rope I think
that whatever that analogy is that I've
heard in culture I'm sure as what I'm
doing which is I'm giving unbelievable
amounts of rope and some people run into
perpetuity with it and create enormous
amounts of happiness and wealth and
success and whatever we do together and
others will you know get tripped up on
it and get caught up in their bungee
cord and loose well first of all I have
always been you know an alpha and I have
always led with gratitude and empathy
and kindness and compassion and caring I
that doesn't always manifest in my
content or on stage when I'm you know
when I have the lights on and I'm my
most showman but I mean that's become
very obvious to anybody that's close to
me and I believe that because the world
is harder to hide from
that over time people will develop
better people skills because that has
always been the thing that mattered but
in a world that you could hide behind
closed doors non-internet non-media and
everybody's fingertips people went to
bad behavior and so yeah i think i think
emotionally intelligent characteristics
and what I would call soft and caring
and fluffy and warm and cuddly and cute
I think are actually enormous strengths
for an alpha male and I do think of it a
lot like the color pink and the color
blue these were the color pink was a
boys color and the color blue is a
girl's color in the early in the late
1800s Early 1900s and it was rebranded
and I think that you know in the 1980s
you know tough and don't show emotions
and don't show weakness and all that
were the kind of like Marlboro Man John
Wayne era and I think that I think that
the way I roll is going to be the next
era now I'm probably both right like I
can be kind of like aggressive and
competitive and show that side but my
absolute strength and foundation to my
success and and and and often other
people's that I admire from afar are
predicated on their empathy and
perspective and gratitude and warmth and
you know I think I think I'm winning on
on that and I think I'm gonna make it
popular and I think a lot of people
gonna feel the benefits of good
I mean emotional intelligence for me I
define emotional intelligence in the
ability to be empathetic the ability to
feel others the ability to be the bigger
person emotionally because you are not
chemically or perspectively
thinking about things in the short term
and you're able to take a step back and
in the heat of the moment bring value
and and just I think feeling people you
know just feeling people and then
knowing what to do with it there's
emotional intelligence and there's the
ability to then
in the fine line turn that into
manipulation because you feel people and
you're able to move them into something
that doesn't benefit them and I think
some of the worst people of all time
have been emotionally intelligence have
had emotional intelligence but they they
transformed it into negative
manipulation and you know and my
ambition is to go the other way which is
to use my emotional intelligence to
create an incredible force of good and I
think emotional intelligence is a little
bit more complex than just charisma you
know I think um I think it's uh and and
you know and I think I think a lot of
times I'll use emotional intelligence or
other things I genuinely believe there's
a conversation to be had around kindness
you know being kind it works it works
but I think there's also like you know I
think I think one thing that people
don't understand is I think I use being
misunderstood as an advantage to get it
accomplished so let's talk about how you
set this up so there's always gonna be a
group that believes in me right away and
there's a belief a group that doesn't
believe in me and then there's the
middle which is the biggest group of all
I think for a lot of those people
they're gonna gravitate towards you know
I always I always say people find what
they're looking for so I feel like the
people that most appreciate my content
right away
are either optimistic and positive in
nature to begin with so they see it or
love candor right and then there's
people who are just cynical because
they've been hurt or negative because
they're negative and I think those
people struggle with me at first but I
do think being misunderstood or having
very polarizing reactions to me is a
strength of mind because I can slow roll
people in to where I'm looking to get
them mentally in my own selfish ambition
to like do good I'm not hung up on it
like whether I'm right or your buddies
are right
like somebody's gonna be right in the
end you know I like spending time
debating if I'm a good dude or not if
I'm like if I'm really real or not you
know if I'm full of [ __ ] or not is
utterly a complete waste of time
boo I'm just [ __ ] gonna do and just
like the score will be the score didn't
matter if you thought LeBron was gonna
be good or not like LeBron took care of
that like so and people will still say
what they're gonna say so I'm okay with
that not judging yourself you've been
talking about this a lot recently and
for whatever reason and I'm trying to
figure out what it is you speak to I
don't judge other people and it starts
with myself and it's a very powerful
thing of course I judge people like but
I don't judge them I guess that you know
you know of course let me rephrase
things run through my minds opinions but
judgment like is like is final it's
absolute and I just think everything's
gonna work in progress or moments in
time or angles or contexts or you need
to know so much more like everybody's
got opinions on people they don't even
first of all first of all this is just
straight [ __ ] facts 99.9% of people
that you judge or have opinions on you
have no idea what the [ __ ] is actually
happening in their lives let's just
start there
the fact is you probably only know what
four or five people actually have going
on and even then you don't know as much
about your sister your parents as you
think so who the [ __ ] are you
I mean that to me is just like I just
have no interest in being so wrong I
care too much about myself to judge
other people like you don't know me and
that means I don't know you and so you
know everything is within context
everybody's so absolute you know world
is gray
YouTube I hope you enjoy that the new
guy he's emerging understand it leave a
comment under two cents if you
understood this episode and please
subscribe subscribe subscribe